[Musique]
mardi 16 janvier bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le 78 sur tv78 voici les titres de
cette
édition le froid ne faiblit pas dans les
ivelines le département et le reste de
l'Île-de-France sont placés en vigilance
orange à la neige et au Vergl à partir
de ce mardi soir 22h des flocons ainsi
que des pluies vertglaçantes sont
attendues ont fait le point les travaux
de la ligne 18 avanceent le métro doit
relier Versailles à l'aéroport d'Orly en
2030 mais une poignée d'habitants
dénonce l'artificialisation des terres
agricoles et reste fermement opposé à ce
projet réuni en collectif une trentaine
de personnes ont marché dimanche entre
guyancour et Châteaufort pour réclamer
l'arrêt du chantier une collaboration
désormais officiel le musée
départemental maurice- Denis situé à
Saint-Germain en lait et le célèbre
musée d'Orsay ont signé hier une
convention de partenariat scientifique
en clair des prêts et dépôt d'œuvrees
vont venir enrichir les collections du
City vlinois explication et puis dans
l'invité du 78 en 2è partie d'émission
la suite de nos interviews avec les
maires de Saint-Quentin en Yveline ce
soir Nicolas d'ville sera avec nous il
est le maire de
Laverrière dans le 78 également ce soir
décryptage de la transformation de Pôle
Emploi vers France travail c'est
effectif depuis le 1er janvier la
ministre du Travail Catherine Vautrin
était en déplacement justement hier à gu
en cours sur le sujet ce sera à suivre
tout à l'heure dans le 78 mais
j'accueille tout de suite Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir de la rédaction TV 78 et
avec vous on va faire le point sur les
informations du
jour et j'en parlais dans les titres
information météo la neige va encore
tomber dans les ivelines oui météoance
prévoit des phénomènes météorologiques
dangereux dans le département dès ce
soir conséquence l'alerte orange neige
et Vergl a été déclenchée à partir de ce
mardi 16 janvier 22h une alerte qui
devrait être maintenue jusqu'à jeudi
matin des chutes de neige sont notamment
annoncées mercredi on écoute ce
météorologiste de
météorance pourquoi on attend donc cet
épisode donc on a effectivement une
masse d'air froid qui donc persiste sur
le nord du pays et une dépression hène
qui donc apporte de l'air plus doux et
humide par le sud et donc ce conflit de
masse d'air va donner des précipitations
hivernales sous forme de pluiv ver
glçant ou de neige ce qui est important
à préciser c'est que dans ce temps bien
hivernal on aura donc des déplacements
qui vont être rendus difficile voire
dangereux c'est pourquoi il faut bien
rester très vigilant donc pour cet
épisode des prochains jours et continuer
de suivre donc l'évolution de nos
prévisions on attend donc par le sud
déjà dès le le milieu fin de soirée un
premier saoudrage de neige assez faible
par rapport à ce qu'on pourra avoir
ultérieurement en nuit de mercredi à
jeudi et puis donc ensuite ce
saupoudrage de fin de soirée va vite
être remplacé par des pluies vert
glçantes donc prudence pour les
ivelinois face à ce saupoudrage mais on
l'a compris c'est un épisode qui
pourrait durer on aura l'occasion de
donner d'autres informations aux
ivelinois dans nos éditions prochaines
sur tv78 dans l'actualité également
Gabriel des actes antisémites qui ont
été perpétrés dans les iilines alors
parmi les derniers épisodes en date et
dimanche midi des des tags antisémites
découverts près du stade montboron c'est
à versaill oui par ces tags des signes
SS de croix celti une étoile de David et
des slogans hostiles aux Juifs ont été
retrouvés sur une palissade municipale
passage de l'abbis Picard pour le moment
les auteurs n'ont pas été retrouvés des
tagainux ont aussi été retrouvés
dimanche soir cette fois c'était à
viroflet deux personnes ont été arrêtées
appartement toutes deux à une mouvance
d'extrême droite à garganville une
étrange histoire d'intoxication
alimentaire ça se passe dans un collège
oui tout à fait grégoryi des dizaines
d'élèves du collège Albert cam ont été
victimes de symptômes gastriques après
avoir déjeuné à la cantine ce lundi midi
des pompiers et plusieurs équipes de
SAMU ont été dépêché sur place pour
prendre en charge les malades ils
auraient été intoxiqués avec une sauce
barbecue selon les premiers témoignages
une enquête a été ouverte on parle
maintenant de la ville de trappe le
jumelage avec la Comédie Française se
poursuit oui et c'était ce lundi un
quart de trapiste s'est rendu à la
Comédie Française pour la représentation
annuelle d'hommage à Molière un part
partenariat qui va s'intensifier dans
les prochains mois les habitants
bénéficient désormais de modalités et de
tarifs privilégiés les modalités sont à
retrouver sur le site de la mairie le
jumelage entre les deux institutions a
pu voir le jour grâce à l'action d'Alain
Degois dit papi fondateur de la
Compagnie des clic théâtre enfin du côté
de Rambouillet la fréquentation en 2023
du Château de Rambouillet est en hausse
oui plus de 62000 visiteurs accueillis
en 2023 c'est 9 % he de plus qu'en 2022
pour l'établissement ces chiffres
confirment l'attractivité touristique du
lieu un chiffre haut malgré un parcours
de visite amputé l'appartement de
l'empereur est enfermé pour restauration
parmi ces 62000 visiteurs près de 35 %
bénéficient de la gratuité donc les
moins de 26 ans les demandeurs d'emploi
ou encore les personnes en situation de
handicap le château confirme sa bonne
fréquentation en 2022 il comptait déjà
plus de 40 % de visiteur par rapport à
2019 bien sûr les années covid sont
mises de côté la fréquentation ayant
chuté avec les fermetures et les
restrictions merci Gabriel vous restez
avec nous car dans un instant vous allez
nous parler de ce partenariat entre le
musée départemental Maurice Denis et le
musée d'orset à Paris et si vous aussi
he pour ces informations près de chez
vous vous êtes justement témoin d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
evelines et n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
new
depuis le 1er janvier paôul emploi est
devenu France travail une transformation
qui amène son lot de changement avec un
objectif atteindre le plein emploi le
plein emploi en France hier justement la
nouvelle ministre du Travail Catherine
Vautrin se rendait dans une agence
France travail à guyancour sur le sujet
le reportage de Clara de Frutos et
Patrick Jacques de dixmud c'est l'un des
grands changements de ce début d'année
2024 Paul emploi devient France travail
depuis le 1er janvier après l'adoption
de la loi pour le plein emploi le 18
décembre dernier le gouvernement
souhaite renforcer le suivi des
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
mais pas que la deuxième des choses
c'est d'accompagner toutes les
entreprises parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'on offre des
services pour accompagner les
entreprises à plus recruter à mieux
recruter ça fonctionne bien 86 % d'entre
elles sont satisfaites sauf qu'on a
encore 70 % des entreprises qui
n'utilisent pas France travail mais
France travail ne va pas seulement
changer de nom l'organisme se réorganise
pour mieux coordonner l'accueil
l'orientation l'insertion ou encore la
formation des demandeurs d'emplo il sera
notamment intégré à un réseau pour
l'emploi un réseau qui se constitue en
quatre
[Musique]
entités autre changement une inscription
automatisée à France travail est prévu
pour les personnes sans emploi au plus
tard en 2025 cette mesure concerne les
demandeurs d'emploi déjà inscrits à
Pemploi les jeunes et les personnes
handicapées accompagnées par des
missions locales ou Cap emploi mais
aussi les bénéficiaires du revenu de
solidarité active et leur conjoint si
nécessaire après cette inscription un
diagnostic approfondi est ensuite
réalisé auprès des demandeurs d'emploi
pour définir un contrat d'engagement son
but délimiter un plan d'action pour
atteindre des objectifs d'insertion
sociale et professionnelle cette loi
fixe aussi une obligation d'activité
d'au moins 15 heures par semaine des
nouveautés en cours d'application pour
l'occasion la nouvelle ministre du
Travail Catherine Vautrin s'est déplacé
à l'agence de Guill encs elle a échangé
avec conseillers et entreprises autour
de deux thématiques l'accompagnement des
entreprises pour favoriser le retour à
l'emploi et le renforcement de ces aides
auprès des publics l'émancipation de nos
concitoyens se fait par le travail
l'idée c'est de les aider à retrouver un
emploi et ici dans ce département on a
AG Guill encour une commune qui dispose
d'un nombre d'entreprises extrêmement
important nous avons échangé avec
plusieurs d'entre elles qui ont montré
combien depuis 6 mois elles avai elles
avaient eu des réponses l'Agence France
travail de guillencour expérimente
depuis quelques mois avec 17 are site en
France une démarche pour faciliter le
retour ou l'accès à l'emploi des
allocataires de
RSA les opposants à la ligne 18 c'était
donné rendez-vous le weekend dernier
dimanche une marche a réuni une
trentaine de personnes sur une partie du
tracé du métro pour une marche entre Guy
encour et Châteaufort ses opposants
dénoncent l'artificialisation des terres
agricoles du plateau de sacclet Julien
Leroi et Mélanie poet on est sur un des
ouvrages annexes donc l'ouvrage 19 donc
ça veut dire qu'il y en a au moins une
vingtaine pour aller à versaill on
arrête tout c'est le mot d'ordre de la
mobilisation organisée par le collectif
contre la ligne 18 et
l'artificialisation des terres ce
dimanche 14 janvier une grande marche
intitulée toxique tour entre guillancour
et Châteaufort était menée sur le tracé
des futurs rails pour rappel ce métro
aérien devrait relier l'aéroport d'Orly
à la gare de versailleschantier de 2030
une aberration pour les membres
dénonçant le tronçon aérien au milieu
des champs du plateau de sacelet ça
implique une coup
fragment
paysage une rupture des corridors
écologiques sur le plateau de saclé il y
a il y avait six corridors écologiques
avantarrivée de la ligne 18 il y en a C
qui sont supprimés il en reste un 6e qui
est très en danger et qui va rompre la
circulation de la fune sauvage entre les
forêts de rambouillé et la forêt de
Versailles sachant qu'une ligne de métro
va appeler forcément l'aménagement du
territoire c'est c'est la politique
officielle et que donc à long terme vous
allez avoir un territoire qui sera très
urbanisé et donc potentiellement les Z
vont y passer quoi le collectif dénonce
la future structure aérienne en béton
armée du métro elle impliquerait
l'artificialisation de 22 hectares de
terres agricoles où les nuisances
sonores du au futur RAM pour les
habitations alentour malgré l'avancée
galoppante des travaux les militants
espèrent encore un retour en arrière
pour cette ligne 18 il y a eu quand même
l'année dernière plein d'éléments
nouveaux il y a une nouvelle l'étude sur
l'impact sur la biodiversité il y a les
agriculteurs qui qui continuent à
protester sur le fait que ça va les
empêcher de de déployer leur activité il
y a des élus en particulier dans les son
qui qui qui ont dit que c'était pas
possible de continuer comme ça c'est la
proposition du collectif envisager un
moratoire pour se poser et regarder tous
ces éléments nouveaux qu'il y a eu en
2023 cette marche d'une trentaine de
personnes s'inscrivaent dans le cadre
d'un grand weekend de rassemblement
assemblé atelier cré sur la biodiversité
et spectacle était aussi au programme du
côté de Manil les amo une mobilisation
pour espérer voir ce projet de plus de
20 ans
s'interrompre allez c'est l'heure des
actualités culturelles dans le
[Musique]
78 le 30 janvier prochain le théâtre
Alfonse d'udet de coignère accueille la
Nuit des rois c'est une pièce de
Shakespeare qui est présentée par la
compagnie le lendemain d'hier et mise en
scène par Benoît faseras et nowen Cosmao
la directrice du Théâtre Alphonse donet
vous donne trois raisons de ne pas
manquer ce spectacle c'est au micro de
Mathilde Francou bonjour je suis Gwenola
bigouin la directrice de l'espace
Alphonse d'udé à coagère aujourd'hui je
vous conseille un spectacle La Nuit des
rois d'après
[Musique]
Shakespeare alors la première euh bonne
raison de voir ce spectacle c'est un
classique mais accessible à tous la mise
en scène est contemporaine par exemple
les décors en fait sont minimalistes ce
qui laisse place à l'imagination et
cetera les costumes sont entre hier et
aujourd'hui et surtout le langage est
actuel la deuxième bonne raison c'est un
spectacle dynamique avec six comédiens
pour 15 personnages c'est un spectacle
où on danse où on chante ou on
s'interpelle comme au 17e siècle mais
son des guitares la troisème bonne
raison c'est une joyeuse farandole une
fresque musicale et clownesque qui
célèbre la fête le travestissement et
l'amour surtout et en cet an morose ça
ne peut faire que du bien bon parle
sérieusement Satis fa de l'effet comme
de l'au de vie sur une sage femme pas ru
[Musique]
elle
pleure
ENF maintenant c'était donc les trois
bonnes raisons pour voir la Nuit des
[Musique]
rois dans l'actualité culturelle hier le
musée départemental Maurice Denis situé
à Saint-Germain en lait et le musée
d'orsin ont signé une convention de
partenariat scientifique alors Gabriel
Gontier vous étiez sur place ça
représente quoi cette convention et bien
cette signature grégoryi elle
offficialise le lien qui unit les deux
musées alors depuis de nombreuses années
car depuis l'ouverture du musée
départemental Maurice deis c'était en
1980 les deux institution collabor
ensemble l'objectif avec cette signature
c'est donc d'inscrire et de faire
perdurer ce lien et ce partenariat il va
permettre plusieurs choses notamment
davantage de prêt entre le les musées ce
qui va contribuer à l'enrichissement des
collections du musée Maurice Denis on a
interrogé le président du musée d'Orsa
sur cette collaboration ce partenariat
entre le musée d'Orsy et le musée
Maurice Denis est un une alliance pour
que le musée d'Orsy puisse apporter son
concours non seulement par des prêts
d'œuvre des dépôts mais aussi un soutien
scientifique pour les projets de
publication les projet d'exposition et
puis tout ce qui peut se se présenter à
l'avenir pour renforcer le le prestige
et l'attractivité du musée Maurice Denis
alors ce partenariat il a été signé pour
5 ans il s'inscrit également dans la
volonté du d'ors de développer des
coopérations en dehors de Paris et cette
signature devrait permettre également de
mieux connaître ce musée Maurice Denis
et aussi ses collections oui si le musée
départemental est bien inscrit dans le
territoire des Yvelines depuis de
nombreuses années les œuvres de
l'artiste ivelinois restent encore mal
connu ce partenariat va permettre plus
de visibilité au musée c'est ce que nous
explique le président du Département
Pierre Bédier nous allons pouvoir
grâce à ce partenariat pouvoir mieux
faire connaître ce musée qui souffre
d'un déficit de communication parce que
il est absolument
extraordinaire le lieu est magique
l'œuvre de Maurice Denis est d'une d'une
richesse d'un foisonnement exceptionnel
et donc ça va être une aide à la
communication et puis ça va être une
aide à l'approfondissement de la
connaissance de l'œuvre à la démarche
scientifique bon vous l'avez compris les
œuvres de Maurice Denis ont encore de
belles années devant elle une bonne
nouvelle pour le patrimoine yvelinois
car la grande majorité d'étoile de
l'artiste ont été peintes dans les
ivines dans son atelier de Saint-Germain
en lait merci Gabriel on l'a compris
intéressé par le patrimoine vous êtes
intéressé aussi par l'histoire un petit
peu aussi et bien justement maxour de la
croué nous en apprend un peu plus sur
l'histoire du département chaque mardi
ce jeune passionné d'histoire se fixe
pour mission de vous conter des
anecdotes méconnues le tout en une
minute et ce soir Maxence met à
l'honneur le château de Marle Leroi
domaine prisé par un certain Louis XIV
le château de Marl n'est que très peu
évoqué lorsque l'on veut parler du
quotidien de Louis XIV
[Musique]
il a pourtant été le théâtre de moment
plus intime du roi lorsque celui-ci
voulait échapper à la pesanteur de la
cour il résume ainsi les fonctions de
ces trois résidences j'ai fait versaill
pour ma cour Trianon pour ma famille
Marley pour mes amis il qualifie même
Marley d'antiversaill ce qui montre
l'importance de vivre autrement qu'au
domaine royal seul quelques privilégiés
étaient invités à Marley cela faisait
partie d'une des faveurs royales les
plus importantes ce château était avant
tout un lieu de fête de réception et de
loisir mais le roi soleil avait
également pour habitude de recevoir des
entités politiques et administratives
comme si certaines affaires étaient
traitées plus secrètement loin du noble
tumulte de Versailles le château de
marlie est finalement détruit avec
l'avènement du Premier Empire et la
chute de l'ancien
régime avant l'invité du 78 coup d'œil
aux prévisions météo de
demain et je vous rappelle la principale
information de cette édition avec cette
vigilance orange dans les zvelines
activé à partir de ce soir 22h et
jusqu'à au moins demain une vigilance
orange pour la neige et le verglas des
flocons et des pluies verglassantes sont
attendu dans toute l'île-de-fance
prudence les températures seront-elles
légèrement positives dès la matinée de
mercredi ce qui pourrait favoriser
justement ce phénomène de pluie
verglçante l'après-midi les pluies se
transforment en brume dans les secteurs
ouest et sud du département le mercure
baissera par endroit comptez 2°gr à
Oudan et Rambouillet et 3°gr à
Versailles et la jolier ce mercredi 17
janvier nous fêterons les antoinees tout
de suite l'invité du
[Musique]
78 à quoi s'attendre pour 2024 à
Saint-Quentin en Eveline tout au long du
mois de janvier les maires de
l'agglomération viennent en plateau pour
parler des grands dossiers des grands
projets pour cette année dans leur
commune et ce soir c'est Nicolas
d'unville qui est avec nous bonsoir
bonsoir maire de La Verrière également
vice-président de 50 ans nieline délégué
à l'emploi à la formation
professionnelle et à l'apprentissage
déjà bonne année à vous et également au
verrierrois qui nous regardent ce soir
avant qu'on parle de 2024 qu'est-ce que
vous retenez de l'année 2023 à La
Verrière vous avez dit dans vos vœux en
vidéo que ça a été les les montagnes
russes ben effectivement c'est vraiment
l'image qui me me vient à l'esprit les
montagnes russes beaucoup de haut et et
aussi beaucoup de bas on a vécu des
moments très difficiles des épreuves
avec les émeutes qui ont touché tant de
communes en France et la verrian a
malheureusement on pas été épargné avec
deux écoles qui ont brûlé des moments
très marquants pour les enseignants pour
les familles pour les enfants pour les
élus pour les agents qui ont été
extraordinaires et des moments aussi
incroyables que j'aurais même pas pu
imaginer dans le meilleur de mes rêves
avec notamment le parinis le départ euh
qui était un moment incroyable de fierté
de rayonnement assez extraordinaire
parinis qui s'est lancera une nouvelle
fois du département cette année puisque
chaque année il y a une convention qui
lit le parinis avec le le département
alors vous avez parlé de cet épisode des
émeutes qui a touché de manière
importante votre commune on parle d'ici
des écoles maternelles primaires aussi
du quartier du Bois de l'étan qui ont
été détruites par un incendie 30
millions d'euros de de dégâts en tout
les élèves ont fait leur rentrée à
l'école régionale du premier degré ce
qui a été rendu possible grâce aussi au
soutien de la Région Île-deFrance est-ce
que le choc est toujours présent
aujourd'hui dans les têtes des des
verrierrois dans la vôre aussi écoutez
je trouve qu'il y a eu un esprit de
résilience assez extraordinaire il y a
eu un choc terrible le le le lendemain
du du drame et très vite on on s'est
organisé avec des partenaires
incroyables le préfet Courtat qui était
là le le matin même qui a je dirais
permis aussi d'impulser la cellule de
crise le rectorat qui a permis de
d'organiser des sorties pour aérer
l'esprit des enfants la région qui a
répondu à notre appel très vite a permis
d'aménager en un temps record des salles
dans cette école que vous venit
d'évoquer le RPD avec tous les les
agents de le RPD nos agents qu'on
récoltait des dons le département sur
lequel on travaille toutes les semaines
pour la reconstruction et puis bien
évidemment Saint-Quentin qui finance
aussi les navettes donc il y a eu une
coordination des acteurs de précieux
soutiens qui ont fait front comme vous
l'avez dit avec la ville de la verriia
avec les verrierrois pour trouver des
solutions concrètes en un temps record
puisque la rentrée arrivé à grand pas et
on a pu organiser cette rentrée je
dirais dans les meilleures conditions et
le groupe scolaire va être construit
exactement le le le les les groupes
scolaires va être construit il y a des
délis qui malheureusement sont toujours
très longs en France on a des procédures
d'appel d'offre il y a des sujets
financiers faut quand même trouver bien
évidemment les les les les financements
les fonds et donc on espère d'ici 2 ans
et demi 3 ans pouvoir offrir
l'excellence auquelle les enfants du du
bois de l'étan ont le droit euh en tout
cas on se retrousse les manches on se
donne énormément de mal c'est ça nous
prend beaucoup de temps mais ça donne
aussi du sens à la mission alors
puisqu'on parle du bois de l'étan il y a
un gros dossier à l'avriè vous le
qualifiez vous-même de projet du siècle
celui de la rénovation urbaine de ce
quartier du Bois de l'éan 616 logements
alors dans les grandes lignes il prévoit
une réhabilitation de plus de 400
logements une démolition de plus de 200
logements la mise en place d'équipements
l'objectif c'est désenclaver le quartier
on parle ici d'un d'un projet à hauteur
de de 78 millions d'euros qui est mené
dans le cadre de l'anrue he l'Agence
nationale de la rénovation urbaine le
relogement des habitons à à débuter ça
va se poursuivre cette année alors
affirmatif on a réalisé 50 % du
relogement donc on est très heureux de
ce seuil symbolique qui a été franchi
avec un rythme de 4 à 6 relogements par
mois donc on a une très belle cadence le
bailleur séquence la préfecture l'agloot
l'interbailleur les maires qui nous
aident pour le relogement donc on est
très heureux et puis les réhabilitations
vont vont débuter c'est des
réhabilitations massives he vous avez
cité les chiffres là on par parle d'un
ratio de plus de 100000 € par logement
c'est un ratio hein donc ça part ça
comprend le logement et les parties
communes mais du sol au plafond tout va
être fait les volets l'électricité les
canalisations les boîtes au letettes les
holdimmeubles les isolations les
ascenseurs il était temps qui vont être
intégralement remplacés bref c'est un
investissement massif pour redonner de
la qualité de vie et de l'attractivité à
ce quartier qui mérite le meilleur donc
réhabilitation qui démarre cette année
hein cette année 2024 exactement autre
grand projet la verrière son nom de le
nom de ce projet c'est gare bécadee
alors on parle ici de la partie nord de
la verrière autour de la gare le long de
la voie ferrée et de la nationale 10 on
est tout proche du quartier horly Park
dans les grandes lignes on parle ici de
1500 logements 60000 m² de pôle
d'activité économiques des nouveaux
services là aussi l'objectif c'est
désenclaver cette partie de la ville et
là on parle ici d'un projet qui est en
fait directement en lien avec le
réaménagement de la de la gare de La
Verrière est-ce qu'on aura du nouveau
cette année oui on a déjà eu beaucoup de
nouveaux puisque la gare avance bien il
y a le nouveau parking qui est sorti de
terre qui est ouvert avec plus de 900
places il y a ce beau parvis qui va être
inauguré cette année en 2024 un parvis
piéton pour vraiment faire de la gare
qui a un élément d'attractivité
incroyable dans une ville un vrai lieu
de vie c'est un quartier qui était
totalement délaissé dans le passé nous
on on croit au contraire que ce lieu
peut être une
locomotive pour le commerce pour les
services pour en faire un lieu vraiment
convivial
et puis le projet euh des bécanes he ce
terrain qui est à proximité de la gare
c'est un projet aussi de moyen terme
tout tout est très lent en France c'est
parfois un peu frustrant mais on espère
les premiers coups de pioche d'ici d'ici
5 6 ans tout est très l mais pour avoir
un cœur de ville cœur de ville avec cet
esprit village qui permett de redonner
de la centralité de l'attractivité du
dynamisme avec des nouveaux commerces
avec des nouveaux services notamment en
terme de santé puisqu'on manque
cruellement de médecins mais pour être
attractif pour des médecins il faut plus
de de patients une patientelle plus
importante et puis
d'avoir aussi je dirais ce ce fameux
cœur de ville dans le parcours
résidentiel qui permettent à tous ceux
qui veulent acheter à la verrière de
pouvoir le faire on a vu quelques images
d'e marche que vous avez mené avec les
habitants pour recueillir sur ce projet
leurs impressions alors en 2024 on parle
aussi d'autres nouveautés plusieurs
projets qui con concerne le le quotidien
des habitants alors il y a des
aménagements pour les cyclistes
notamment à l'allée du 19 mars et tout
autre chose des des boîtes àèes vont
être installés c'est ça exactement on a
les boîtes à lire qui vont être
installées pour démocratiser l'accès à
la lecture on a déjà la chance à La
Verrière d'avoir une belle médiathèque
etim sesir j'vite d'ailleurs tous les
verrierrois à à à à s'y rendre mais on a
envie de d'avoir aussi des lieux de
convivialité elles seront en forme de
cabine téléphonique anglaise les les Red
teléphone boxes j'espère que vous ne
vous moquerez pas de mon accent non non
pas du tout et en fait c'est un petit
clin d'œil aussi à la visite du roi
Charles I dans les Yvelines visite
historique dans notre département et et
et donc on a voulu faire ce ce petit
clin d'œil là vous parliez des
aménagements cyclables il y en aura en
fait effectivement sur l'avenue des Noé
et également sur la la rue du du petit
pont et puis l'avenue de la gare pour
permettre de relier ces ces ces ces
grandes je dirais liaisons de manière
sécurisée pour les cy pour inverser le
rapport de force pour faire comprendre
aux automobilistes que la priorité c'est
le cycliste et puis l'allée du 19 mars
qui va être totalement réaménagée elle
va se refaire une beauté elle est très
appréciée des verrierrois mais elle
était assez véuste et donc il fallait
investir pour lui redonner un un nouveau
souffle et puis en 2024 il y a un
événement je pense que vous voyez où je
veux envenir bien sûr les les Jeux
Olympiques c'est une année olympique la
verrière à ce label de terre de jeu
comment la commune va-t-elle tout
simplement s'associer à l'événement
comment vous allez le le vivre avec vos
habitants et ben écoutez en en
s'inscrivant pleinement dans cet
événement qui est aussi l'événement du
siècle puisque je crois que les derniers
jeux c'est en France cétait il y a plus
de 100 ans 1924 1924 donc on va essayer
de participer pleinement à la fan zone
qui sera sur l'île de loisir on essaie
aussi de relayer beaucoup les offres
d'emploi on parle de 10000 offres
d'emploi dans des secteurs très
recherchés en tension la sécurité la
restauration l'hôtellerie mais aussi les
transports donc on va s'inscrire
pleinement dans cette dynamique d'emploi
et puis il y aura beaucoup d'événements
pour gagner des places alors les places
elles sont très limitées malheureusement
on a une centaine de places donc ça va
partir très vite mais on va essayer que
nos habitants notamment nos jeunes nos
associations puissent en bénéficier avec
des des quiz des événements sportifs qui
seront organisés tout au long de l'année
pour terminer Nicolas d'Inville la carte
blanche tous les maires qui viennent ici
en en plateau se prêtent à cet exercice
vous abordez un sujet libre qui vous
tient à cœur pour refermer cette
interview vous avez une minute et je
crois que vous allez nous parler de
l'histoire de la ville ben écoutez sujet
essentiel on va effectivement travailler
sur la rédaction d'un beau livre sur
l'histoire de la ville d'une belle
exposition et pourquoi pas d'un
spectacle ens suite sur l'histoire de
notre commune qui est trop souvent
méconnue alors qu'elle est extrêmement
riche on a la cette fameuse gare qui a
été inaugurée par Napoléon II il y a les
temps des Noé qui était créé pour
alimenter les grandes eaues du château
de Versailles les magnifique fontaine
mais aussi les premiers lotissements
pour les parisiens en manque de campagne
à la petite verrière et puis l'histoire
du château qui est extraordinaire avec
ce compte de la Valette qui était l'IDE
de camp de Bonaparte et qui a caché l'un
des des trésors l'un des vraiment
beaucoup de de de d'argent notamment de
la campagne d'Égypte qui était caché
sous le plancher du château la légende
voudrait que une partie seulement de ce
trésor a été trouvé si vous trouvez
l'autre moitié on est toujours preneur
he pour les finances communale mais on
va vraiment faire ça en récoltant les
les les anecdotes les souvenirs précieux
de des habitants il y a beaucoup
d'habitants qui ont vécu des choses
extraordinaires dans la ville qui ont
énormément de choses à raconter et ça
serait bête que toute cette mémoire vive
tombe dans l'oubli et donc l'intérêt
c'est vraiment de le faire avec les
habitants et le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin pour vraiment qu'on qu'on
renforce ce sentiment d'appartenance
cette fierté cette identité verrièroise
qui est si belle merci beaucoup Nicolas
d'ville d'avoir été avec nous maire de
La Verrière une nouvelle fois bonne
année à vous et à la commune de La
Verrière pour cette année 2024 voilà
c'est la fin du 78 merci de votre
fidélité et demain pour une nouvelle
édition vous retrouverez Mathilde
Francou à la présentation belle soirée
sur
[Musique]
tv78